YUFENG GUO: Sometimes
there's a misconception
that Google Cloud
only runs TensorFlow.
Well, there are many deep
learning libraries out there.
And GCP runs much more
than just TensorFlow.
How do we get other
machine learning
libraries running on GCP?
Stay tuned to find out.
[DIGITAL BLIP]
[BEEP]
Welcome to "AI
Adventures," where
we explore the art, science,
and tools of machine learning.
My name is Yufeng Guo.
And on this episode
we're going to see how
to run PyTorch on Google Cloud.
There's a lot of options.
So let's dive right in.
If you want to get
your hands on PyTorch
and have no
installation or setup,
then there's,
well, no easier way
to do so than using something
like Colab or Kaggle kernels.
You can just sign in
with your Google account,
and you're ready to use PyTorch.
Just import and go.
Colab has a neat GitHub
integration additionally
that allows you to pull in any
public IPython notebook file
on GitHub directly into Colab.
So if you're working
through an examples repo,
and you want to try
modifying and running
the code for yourself,
it's super easy.
You can just go to File, Open
Notebook, select the GitHub
tab, and paste in the URL of the
repository or that user's name.
You can also link directly
to a GitHub notebook in Colab
by copying the URL that
comes after GitHub.com,
and pasting it directly
after Colab.research.g
oogle.com/GitHub, which
we are showing here.
Now, on the Kaggle
side of things,
there is a vast
library of kernels
available from the
community across many data
sets, often with excellent
discussion and annotations.
So you don't have to
start from scratch.
And, again, you
don't have to worry
about installing anything
or doing configuration.
Just sign in, and you're
ready to edit your code.
Another option for
the PyTorch developers
out there are the deep
learning virtual machines,
which we've covered a couple
different ways on this show.
You can select an image that
is pre baked with PyTorch,
alongside any Nvidia drivers
you may need for GPUs
that you might choose to attach.
This option is
great if you really
want to crank up
that compute power
and have full control
over your environment,
including being able to
save your work directly
to your virtual
machine, as opposed
to Google Drive on Colab
or onto Kaggle kernels.
Finally, I want to
point out that Google
is working with the PyTorch team
to enable TensorBoard support
to visualize training progress,
as well as TPU support.
So considering that you can
run Colab with TPUs for free,
that's going to be
an awesome combo.
So if you're overflowing with
ideas about how you'd like
to use Cloud TPUs with
PyTorch, email the team
at PyTorch-TPU@googlegroups.com
to tell them what types
of PyTorch workloads you
would most be interested
in accelerating.
There are options to suit all
kinds of PyTorch use cases
on GCP.
Whether you are looking
to just get started,
or if you're looking to
spin up a big training job,
there's a solid
PyTorch friendly way
to get it done on Google Cloud.
Thanks for watching this episode
of Cloud "AI Adventures."
And if you enjoyed it, be
sure to hit that Like button.
And subscribe to get all
the latest episodes right
when they come out.
For now, jump over to
your favorite environment
to run PyTorch on GCP today.
[MUSIC PLAYING]